e
e e
Christian
[Music]
hello thank you
Anna although I I can really speak loud
enough but you know that's okay
welcome we're glad you're here my name
is cat my pronouns are she her or her
she like the candy bar however you want
to look at it I've been wanting to do
that I'm
sorry we're glad you're here this
evening and I've missed being here I
haven't been here in a few weeks
so I have a couple of announcements um
if you're interested in being baptized
we will offer a baptism class after the
service on December the 8th December the
15th and January the 5th it will be a
fairly short class about 20 to 30
minutes the baptisms will occur during
the service on Sunday January 12th sign
up for the class by scanning the QR
code because of scheduling challenges we
are going to do our Christmas Eve
service here on Sunday December 22nd it
will be a family friendly service where
the kiddos stay with us Nursery will be
a available we'll sing Christmas carols
like candles all the things we normally
do at Christmas uh in the special season
so mark your calendars for Sunday
December 22nd for our special Christmas
Eve on not Christmas Eve
service these candles are a sign of the
presence of
Christ fully Divine and fully
[Music]
human please stand as you're able as
we're entering into our call to worship
and our time of
[Music]
worship now we exit the kingdom of noise
hurry and
productivity and now we enter the
kingdom of
Silence
Stillness and
Grace now we enter Sacred
Space a space for
prayer worship and
adoration a space to encounter Christ
revelation of God heartbeat of
creation may love find you find us
may we all come
home thank you
Cat and as we stand together I just
welcome you guys into a space where um
there's no judgment or separation here
but we have come together gathering
together as the Saints of Christ the
children of God to grasp how wide and
how deep and how long is the love of
Christ so let's do that tonight as we
sing Gary's going to get us started so
you guys can follow
[Music]
him sometimes on this journey get lost
in my mistake
days looks to me like weaknesses a
canvas for you
strength my story isn't over my story's
just
begun failure won't Define me that's
what my father
does you won't find me that's what my
father
[Music]
does lay your burdens down
here in the father's house check your
shame at the
door welcome
anymore you're in the father's house
[Music]
rival's not the end game the Journey's
where you are you never want it perfect
you just want in my heart and the story
isn't over if the story isn't
good faur
never when the father's in the
room failur never find when the father's
in the room wo wo
lay your burdens down wo
wo here in the father house check your
shame at the door it a't welcome
anymore you're in the father's house
prod goh come
home help us find
Hope Love Is On The Move when the
father's in the
room
sing there come to life
love is on the mo where the father's in
the
room mirales take
placeing find F love is breaking through
when the father's in the
room
shing
shing love is breaking through when the
father's in the room yeah yeah breaking
through when the father's in the room
oh lay your burdens down
oh here in the father's house check his
shame at the
[Music]
door the father's
o no shame here no fear
[Applause]
here you're in the father's
[Music]
house all right
kiddos you know the
drill we will see you guys after service
thank you kids ministry team Maggie
and Abby no Katie Abby's in
here Abby
please no we're very thankful for all of
our um amazing teachers who love on them
week after week and uh it is such a gift
to have people who care about our kids
um the way that you would want people to
care about your kids as a parent you
know that's a a gift to be able to trust
that they're being loved the way that
you want them to be so so grateful
um we're going to move into the prayers
of the people so if you guys would read
read along and say the parts in red
aloud with us and then we'll take a
moment to all lift up what's on our
minds and hearts
tonight Jesus for this city of saxi
Texas and for every city and community
and all who live in them we pray to you
for the Good Earth you have given us and
the wisdom and the will to conserve it
we pray to you for the old and the the
sick for the Widow and the orphan for
the injured and suffering we pray to you
for the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them we pray to you for the
vulnerable and the marginalized and
those unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray to you for those
experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to
you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to you
[Music]
yesu
Johnny for the names and the moments
that we have spoken aloud and for those
that we have kept in our hearts we pray
to you that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your
presence amen
[Music]
I love you
Lord for you have delivered
[Music]
Me Love You
Lord For You have delivered my soul from
Death my feet from stumbling
will walk in the land of the living my
soul from Death my feet from stumbling I
will walk in the land of the living
[Music]
I Love You
Lord you have delivered
me I love you
Lord you have delivered my soul from
Death my Fe from stumbling I will walk
in the land of the living my soul from
Death my feet from stumbling I will walk
in the land of the living
[Music]
I Will Bless You Lord For You Heard My
Cry you reach out my head and you save
my life I Will Bless You Lord For You
hurt mying and the god of Heaven turned
his ear to me I will bless you Lord for
unending love for your grace and mercy
and down from above I Will Bless You
Lord till the very end I will call on
you as long as I may
live I love you
Lord for you have delivered
Me Love You
Lord For You have living
my soul from Death my feet from
stumbling I will walk in the land of the
living my soul from Death my feet from
living
[Music]
oh
sing I lose my
ability I lose my
ability to be afraid when I see the way
you love me
all the feet that held my feet to the
floor it don't hold me
anymore when I see your
face and everything changes in the
radiance of your
smile you got this way up
chasing away
those Shadows that hang
around Lord I P
down
again I'm finding now just who I
[Music]
am lose my
ability to be afraid or when I hear you
you say my
name all the voices that on fill my
head they are gone when you
speak when I see your
face Everything Changes in the
radiance your smile
[Music]
he got this way
of chasing away
those Shadows that hang
around down
again I'm finding out just Who I
Am Lord I fall down again
finding out just who I
[Music]
am goodbye fear and goodbye saying
goodby hopess and
pain I have heard the
father call my name goodby running
goodby hiding goodby heaviness and
hiding the new is come the old is washed
away hell TR hello love I long for
you waitting for this
moment Oh my days hello Mercy hello
peace you have me
my I believe I'll never be
the see your
face Everything Changes in the radiance
of Your
[Music]
Smile got this way up chasing away
those Shadows that hang around
when I see your
face Everything Changes in the radi your
[Music]
smile you got this
way chasing away those Shadows that hang
around Lord I fall down again
I'm finding out just who I
am I fall down
again I'm fting out just to I
Am Lord I fall down
again I'm finding out just who I am
hello joy and hello truth hell love for
you waited for this
moment all my
days God sometimes we're waiting for
that moment where we can take a breath
where we can hold on to some
peace find some hope or some
stability and God I'm grateful for
moments like
these where we can come
together believing that you are our hope
and you are our stability and our
anchor you are our way forward
[Music]
and God we hold on to that truth tonight
we sink Our Roots deep into
it because you are good and you are
faithful and your love is
steadfast so in a world of sinking sand
tonight God we put our feet on
you you are our way and our truth and
our
[Music]
life help us to hang on to
that in Jesus name I pray
[Music]
amen can you guys turn to the people
around you and welcome them make them
feel at home
well Grace and peace welcome to the
table my name is Brett and pronounce he
him and it's really good to be with you
all and uh to welcome you into this
space as always that includes those
joining us online and don't forget to
get your communion stuff for later in
the service and uh anyone here tonight
who is new thank you for for being here
so um
the title of my message this week is
tables and lights and our passage is
Mark Chapter 14 verse 17 and then we'll
skip down to verses 22 through- 24 so
that reads when evening came Jesus
arrived with the 12 while they were
eating Jesus Took bread and when he had
given thanks he broke it and gave it to
his disciples saying take it this is my
body
and uh when he had given thanks he or
sorry I read that then he took a cup and
when he had given thanks he gave it to
them and they all drank from it this is
my blood of the Covenant which is poured
out for many he said to
them so back when uh when all my kids
were younger we had this whole very
involved bedtime
routine and uh it it went basically was
like bath brush books bed so all bees
which is easy to remember and then um
and then we would say a prayer and like
sing a little song or something and then
we'd have this moment it was like the
most important moment the exit you know
and uh I would kind of like walk out and
I would close the door not all the way I
would leave it you know like cracked a
little bit and then I would whisper and
this is when all my kids were sharing
the room and I would whisper and kind of
whisper yell you know in that kind of
intense white parents do like hey no
talking no
talking go to
sleep and then i' kind of close that
door and then I would like step away you
know and wait like all right and then
mags and I would do like a little happy
dance like yes and then just fall
unconscious under our pillows they're
like so exhausted you know in those
early those early years sometimes though
it would go very wrong because I would
like no talking I walk away and like
Clos the door with just a little crack
and a little tiny voice would ring out
from the darkness
Daddy and I would in that moment I would
be so annoyed at having little children
acting like little children you know
it's like come on what are you doing and
uh I'd go back in be like what and they
would say
NightLight
NightLight I was like oh rookie mistake
I forgot the NightLight go back and I
would like plug it in and it would emit
this warm glow that really only a
nightlight can
bring there was uh a few times I've been
on a few overnight um backpacking trips
in my life uh but only one time that I
went uh
solo and uh what alwayss out to me
though about these
trips the dark Ness of the night there
like there's something about you know
backpacking you tend to be out away and
uh so when on this one trip solo into
the Ozark Mountains I had been um I'd
done it like a Friday night so i' gotten
off work so I'd already gotten there by
the time I arrived there kind of the
edge of like Arkansas it was already
evening you know and I had a goal to
make it like a certain number of miles
so I start in and in and of course you
know the sun falls and darkness descends
like a blanket and my nerves started
getting a little bit
jittery uh I just wasn't used to being
out there it was my first time in the
woods alone at night and I remember like
I me it's remarkable how like a little
bird in the
underbrush like snapping twigs and it to
me it sounded like a mountain lion like
it was just like oh my gosh at one point
in
armadillo sauntered across the path and
my little headlamp kind of flashes to it
and I like scream I like almost peed
like it looked like some devilish white
ghost from hell I was just like oh my
God I'm just kind I was a little bit a
little bit uh panicky admittedly and uh
eventually though I made it like far
enough you know and set up camp just
have my little headlamp and it's time to
start a fire and I tell you like there
was no human on the face of the Earth
more grateful for that little flicker of
flame than myself I I guess fire is like
nightlight for
adults and there's a little line from
the Psalms where David says uh you set a
table before me in the presence of my
enemies and uh I think if the darkness
was my
enemy that little flame that was my
table
we used to have this little kind of a a
family ritual we do it was just a few
times we we ever did it was is again
back when kids were younger and we would
uh cook dinner and then turn out all of
the lights in the whole house has anyone
ever done this where you turn out all
the lights and then light just like one
candle right there and eat by candle
light it's like so it was so cool really
we should do it again um and there was
something about kind of the darkness of
the whole home it kind of creates a
little bit of I don't know almost
anxiety like no one really wants to go
there you know it's sort of everything's
dark and and then there's something so
kind of comforting about that light
there in the center of the table it kind
of Drew us all together it's like we
were so grateful to be there together in
that moment
in our passage from Mark that we read
just a few minutes ago it's interesting
that he begins the story with this
little this little
detail he says when evening
came in other words this final meal of
bread and
wine was
occurring just as the sun begins to fade
and darkness begins to
approach and in many ways it's I think
it's a significant little mention not
only because it kind of sets the scene
um in fact I think we have an image of a
famous painting uh of the the lastra
with this kind of glow not only does it
set the scene there for that night but I
think in many ways it's symbolic because
like the darkness was indeed
descending in much more profound ways
than even the disciples at that moment
were grasping I mean tomorrow would be
the day of the cross the day of loss the
day of
betrayal and so here Jesus is he's lived
with these men for three
years he has just poured his heart and
soul into them and now it's his last
night with them and it kind of you know
makes you wonder like what is he gonna
say what's he gonna do you know will he
hand them a book and be like guys this
is everything I taught you you know will
he give them a fiveyear
plan will he give them a little a little
pep talk
perhaps uh
no the uh 20th century missionary and
theologian Leslie Newan said it's quite
remarkable that Jesus did not leave the
world a book or a Systematic Theology or
really like a program or structure of
any
kind instead what Jesus left was a
community
and in light of uh this text I would add
that at the very heart of that
Community is not a
preacher or a worship
band
or even the loving relationships we have
for one another as beautiful and
essential um as all of those things are
but instead at the very heart of this
community
is a
table and at the center of that table is
the
light Christ
himself in bread and in wine this is my
body broken for you this is my blood
shed for
you whenever you eat this bread whenever
you drink this cup
remember remember remember me remember
that I am with you remember that I walk
with you alongside you ahead of you
inviting you forward remember that I am
closer than the air you are breathing
now remember
me and so for 2,000 years the church has
confessed that yes of course in some
sense Christ is always with us through
the spirit but but what the church has
name is that Christ is present in a
really
unique and um a a unique and Powerful
way in the bread and the
cup and so this is why we take communion
at least one of the reasons we take
communion nearly every week here at the
table and it's
also one of the reasons um that I think
it's it's really important as we
approach the season of Advent which will
begin next week and then from there you
go into uh the season of Christmas um I
think it's really appropriate to be just
kind of reentering again on the table
because the promise of
Christmas is precisely the the the
promise of the presence of Christ right
it's all about the the
Incarnation the INF fleshman of the Son
of God in human form that the the
promise is that the one who was present
in Bethlehem is the same one who through
the spirit is present to us in the bread
and in the
wine and so I I kind of
Wonder
um like what might this mean for us as a
as a community like what what might this
kind of call us uh kind of away from and
what might it call us
toward first I I think this calls us
away from placing our hope in
people it's very very easy to come to
church with the
hope that this person will heal me
it often it's sort of one of the leaders
or people on a stage um not always
though not always sometimes it's the our
Meetup leader um just someone we meet
who's very kind to us you know and we
think like oh good oh good like here is
the person you know this is who I need
or can even be a kind of sense of the
community as a whole you know that that
this group of people they will heal me
um and then
inevitably a certain disillusionment
sets in when you start to wonder to
yourself I'm not really
sure that say you know the the worship
team or Brett sermons or or this
particular person or something you know
that they're really going to um be able
to heal
what's kind of broken within
me and that's why I think it's very very
important that we have this moment in
our service and even outside of the
service I think this is where it's also
very important to kind of cultivate a
certain inner life with God we might
call it a a place of prayer or silence
or scripture like a a place where we're
kind of tuning into God but to kind of
keep it here at the table um I think I
think it's very important that we have
this time which we'll celebrate again in
just a few minutes where all of the
humans kind of step to the
side you notice that when we come to the
table like of course there's a few folks
serving and you but you receive it and
then it's you in God now it's you in
Christ and it's a moment of prayer it's
a moment of connection mean even the
word
communion you know which isn't supposed
to be just a kind of religious Hoke word
maybe anything that we hear a lot it
just sort of can you know kind of go
right in in one ear and out the other as
we say you know but but even that word
communion communion what is this talking
about it's a communion a
connecting with
God and and I think it's just incredibly
important especially in kind of modern
Protestant churches and circles that we
learn both as Leaders to kind of give
way to step aside and for each of you to
learn that
ultimately Pastor Brett is not going to
heal what feels broken in
you that's not
happening but but our Our Hope really is
that Christ will meet you that Christ
will meet you you like that's the Hope
okay so first it calls us away from
placing our hope in
people and second it calls us toward
Unity toward
Unity uh I think we often find ourselves
in Conflict uh often even with one
another you know like again the the the
longer you Journey as a church Community
the more chances there are you know this
is where you kind of every relationship
so to speak has like the the honeymoon
period you know where just like oh
they're great they're great they're
great and that can the same thing can
happen in church oh it's wonderful it's
wonder I found the perfect Church can't
believe it out of all the churches I
found the perfect one you know and but
at some point that comes that comes to
an end and we do we we like bump up
against one another you know and we're
like disagreeing whether it's you know
some sort of Doctrine or um uh something
political uh and it could be you know
the like partner or SP sitting next to
us now or it could be the person across
the room you know that we just kind of
feel like oh my gosh like I've seen
their Facebook posts and I just think
they're totally out to lunch you know on
issue XYZ or you know whatever
um and of course they maybe think the
same thing you know in Reverse but what
Paul told the Corinthian
Church is that really to check he said
check your heart check your mind when
you come to the table of the Lord
because
uh we we come to one table and it's
supposed to be a place of unity and
connectedness not only with God but also
with the people right we are the the
mystical Body of Christ as Paul puts it
like we are one body and so what you
don't want to do is sort of come to the
table and it actually be sort of
fraudulent you know a kind of um a fra
fracture you don't want there to be
fractures as we come to the one table
and so what Paul encourages the the
Corinthian Church he says you know if
there's something wrong or something off
uh go to that person like talk with them
do your best to to make it right to work
it
through because there's there's not only
a centering on Christ when we come to
the table but there's also a sense of
unity in
connectedness that happens as we uh
participate as the one body of Christ uh
third and finally it calls us toward
hope toward hope you know for for many
uh well if you were anything like me you
grow up with communion being a rather
gloomy Affair you know it's like pretty
like oh God it's sort of a time to take
you know inventory moral inventory like
what are all my sins this week and you
know um and and what can happen there is
I mean Paul also talks about that of
communion can be a time of confession
and that can be good uh but I think it
often for us becomes a sort of endpoint
like that's what communion is all about
take an inventory what are my sins this
week I confess them as I come to the
table you know uh and and actually what
I would say is that's um that's just a
starting point you might start with that
kind of inventory of am I right with
others am I right kind of in my own
heart what's been off this week you know
you can start there but
ultimately I mean you even think of the
whole story of the Cross doesn't just
end with the cross it doesn't just end
with a broken body and blood poured out
but ultimately uh the crucified one has
become the resurrected
one and and so far from being a purely
kind of gloomy
sad thing you know to reflect on the
cross that that in light of the
Resurrection it kind of casts a light
you know back on the cross where we now
we can't help but see it different and
in other words um when we come forward
it's it's actually a a kind of
remembering and a deeply hopeful act
because the promise is that what God has
done for his son son and servant Jesus
Christ he will one day do for
you for me and for all creation I think
of Romans um I think it's n maybe where
Paul talks about um all creation
groaning just
groans longing for the day of its
Redemption I think as we survey the
world the culture we sense the groaning
don't we we feel the groaning we feel we
see the the pain and the fracture we see
it but as Christians like we are people
of tremendous
hope
hope because again what God has done for
Jesus Christ he will one day do for you
for me for all creation and so that's
our hope again our Hope's not not any
one person or Pastor bread or no no um
our hope our grounding is Jesus Christ
so as we come to the table of the Lord
tonight as we take in the body of Christ
and the bread the blood of Christ in the
wine we reenter on the
light on the presence of Christ
himself in the name of the Father the
Son and the Holy Spirit amen
so the uh the way we'll partake tonight
is we'll just go row by row we'll form
um kind of one line right here in the
middle we practice an open table so if
you're here tonight and you'd like to
participate you're welcome to do that um
remember the red is wine the white is
grape juice and uh finally you can just
partake whenever and however you'd like
some folks like to kneel um others like
to just partake immediately or return to
their chairs but again this is the
moment where the humans step to the side
and you get to just commune with Christ
um yourself so this is the
table not of the
church but of the Lord and it's made
ready for those who love him and for
those who want to love him more so come
you who have much faith and you who have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here long you who
have tried to follow
and you who feel like you
failed
come come because it's the Lord Jesus
himself who invites you and it's his
will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the table
[Music]
if you guys would um stand with us
during this last
song I can't
imagine um this community really without
kind of this song curing so many of our
services and especially a service where
we're focusing in on communion I'm so
grateful to have an inclusive table of
Christ I'm so grateful that there's room
for each one of us and each of our
stories and that God did leave us with
community and so tonight as we sing this
let's come together as a community to
remember
[Music]
that he's made
room that we're invited in that we have
the opportunity to engage together and
to find something deeper something that
gives light something that brings
[Music]
Hope come all proud come all
greedy come on Li come all
shame come all wealthy come receive it
to the table come
today come all broken and come all
needy come all po call
SA come all rulers come be
seated from all sers come
all come to the
table from near and
far come from the
Shadows come out of the
door there's room at the
table we save you
come to the
B come join in the
feast every race and every nation come
all reels come oh gay from the
frenes come to Jesus to a table full of
grace
to the table come and say come to the
table come eat and
drink there's no in
CLE come die with the
King recline at the
table come let down
God you're never
[Music]
stranger just come as you
are come
behold come be
love come
[Music]
accepted come now come
come
[Music]
behold come be
love come
accepted come now
come come
behold come be love
[Music]
come
except come now
come prepared is the
table we're ready to
Fe the party is
wav there's more still to
Fe the Harvest is ready
[Music]
go fill every
SE go live out
[Music]
the as a kingdom
[Applause]
of go live out the
[Music]
mission as a kingdom of PRI
thank you so much for joining us this
evening and always we always want to
thank our online guests as well the
online services have helped me quite a
bit the last few weeks cuz I missed but
I was always be able to touch with the
community dur during that
time if you are new and we would love to
have you fill out a card at the table um
on your way out or scan the QR code on
the screens to fill out an online
visitor
card generosity is a key aspect of a
life of adoration and worship to give
financially you can scan the QR code or
visit the uh the website at the taable
tx.org
we can all use more relational support
and spiritual connection the way that we
do that at the table is through our
meetups uh if you are not yet part of a
Meetup please scan the QR code to find
that one that works for
[Music]
you all right now let me send you out
into your week with this blessing
you can hold out your hands in a posture
to receive or just open your heart to
these
words you are a child of
God
you are a
child of
God this is true on your best day and
this is true on your worst day so as you
go into your week ahead with its yet to
be determined highs and lows and
everything in between go filled with the
assurance that you are
loved you are
worthy you are
accepted just the way you
are and
go filled with God's Holy Spirit and the
desire to extend these same Gifts of
Grace and unconditional love to everyone
you come in contact with be
blessed have a good
week have a good turkey
day and we hope to see you back here
next Sunday good
[Music]
night come be
love come
accepted come now come
come
meold come
[Music]
me come accept
it come
now come now
come come now
[Music]